thank you very much to all of you  for making the films it would be great  to like be in the same room having a  drink and talking about this  you know first shot is the key opening  shot is  like a sell of the body of the film this  is a love story which is pretty much  about  the immense role of projection in the  nature of love  the camera always goes to north america  in our film  we're gonna dive into the system in our  region in our country in latin america  i consider myself as a storyteller and  the theme is about  a storyteller he's able to wait the best  story  at the best moment so for me it was like  rediscovering a certain part of  indian culture or connecting with part  of my culture which i had not  and there are some things about the  narrative which are  very indian they should be in the film  and  and then we created moments for them to  be in the film